so it goes without saying that data is
fundamentally changing the way we see it
engage with the world over the past year
especially data has become a daily
fixture in public communication driving
everything from personal decision making
to public policy
and visualization provides everyone from
scientists to humanists to everyday
people with a means for readily
exploring information using our sense of
sight and our intuitions
so what my research explores is how we
can leverage the brain's ability to make
sense of visual information to design
novel visualization tools for
interactive exploratory data analysis
you can see a subset of these projects
here and with a fantastic team of
students and collaborators we work with
stakeholders to help analysts in domains
ranging from literary scholarship
to biology to emergency response
to make sense of their data and to guide
more effective and efficient decision
making and data exploration
so when we think about data science one
of the first things that comes to mind
is this idea of big data but we're also
seeing challenges in terms of new users
new data variety and complexity and new
questions that people want to tackle
with that data more and more people are
looking to leverage data to the point
where graphs and charts become a common
fixture on the evening news
and more of these folks are approaching
data without formal training and
analytics
further we're developing techniques to
bring data together from different
sources to enrich our perspectives and
applications ranging from social media
analysis to personalized medicine and in
bringing new people and new data forward
we're also raising new questions to be
asked of that data
now many of you might be sitting there
thinking so what why can't we just
compute the right answer and not worry
about any of these problems well we've
seen unprecedented advances in machine
learning that offer us really powerful
computational tools
i don't want to sell that short
but i also want to argue that we still
need to bring people into exploratory
analysis we don't always know what we're
looking for and statistics while
incredibly powerful don't always give us
the information that we need
so let me illustrate this with a quick
example here are four first order
statistics for four different data sets
would you say these four distributions
are pretty similar
many of you have probably guessed that
i'm messing with you a little bit here
so all of these data sets have the same
first order statistics but when i
visualize the data sets they have
qualitatively very different structures
and we can see that immediately here we
have linear trends constants with
outliers and parabolic structures we
have words to describe how this data
behaves and we qualitatively understand
the differences even if we can't readily
enumerate them
but what's happening here
how do we build knowledge and data using
visualizations that we can't with
statistics so i'm going to focus on just
these two scatter plots to try to
explain this
the process of interpreting data happens
over time it starts with our sense of
sight essentially light from the red and
the orange points goes into the eye
fires off a set of signals to start the
process of interpreting information
and at the end of this process we reach
the far side of the spectrum insights
the knowledge that we generate using
visualizations
for example one insight we might infer
from this data is while these data sets
have identical statistics they have
qualitatively different shapes that we
can describe as either linear or
parabolic
but how do we get from our sense of
sight to insight from structures and
patterns to knowledge what is going on
in between well i want to argue that by
understanding the perceptual and
cognitive processes between sites and
insights we can start to understand how
the ways we visualize data determine the
knowledge that people can infer from
that data
and my work models how people generate
knowledge from visualization and uses
these models to create new tools and
techniques for analyzing data
to give you the high level overview of
our research process we generally
achieve these ideas in three phases the
first involves discussions with domain
experts to identify what the problem
they're trying to solve is
and what the current limitations are in
their existing approaches
we then conduct empirical studies to
model how we can optimize our
representations
based on needs and context of the
analysis problem and we use this data to
drive new algorithms for supporting
interactive data exploration and embody
these models and approaches in
interactive exploratory analysis systems
where we develop analysis tools and work
with stakeholders to iterate on those
tools and optimize for their particular
sets of needs
so we've used this process to create new
models guidelines algorithms and systems
across a broad range of applications you
can see the list of broader areas that
we're currently working on in the lab
here i'm happy to jump in in individual
conversations and talk about any of
these areas or other future areas that
might be fun opportunities for us all to
collaborate
but for today i really want to focus on
three specific problem areas that
illustrate this process
so these areas the first of these areas
is automating effective visualization
design and this is a problem that
pervades across domains and it's where
i'll spend most of my times a day
the second of these investigates the
cognitive barriers that current
visualization practices create trying to
figure out how we can make data more
accessible for people with intellectual
and developmental disabilities in the
context of fiscal self-advocacy
and the last thread that i'll talk about
explores how augmented reality mobile
data cloud computing and immersive
analytics all come together to support
situated data analysis in field
operations in earth science and
emergency response
so to get started designing effective is
is just thought out a challenging
problem something as simple as choosing
the right colors requires understanding
how people perceive color how the
semantics of color align with data how
the relationships between colors
highlight key patterns
and if that wasn't already enough
choosing colors that actually look good
together
and this is an important challenge is
color is among the most common methods
for encoding data it's first off pretty
and our brains are actually really
really good at synthesizing it so in my
dissertation work i constructed several
systems for applications in biology that
showed how color usages can increase
scalability by 10-fold or more
however we see color used in all kinds
of visualizations from scatter plots to
surfaces to maps and beyond
but as i mentioned
color is really hard to do writes poorly
designed color encodings may not just
look bad
but can lead to misinterpretation and
have even caused papers to be withdrawn
from top journals like nature and
science
work with doctors done by michelle
barkin and her colleagues show that
effective color choices can actually
improve diagnosis rates by 30 or more so
choosing good colors can actually become
a matter of life and death
two of the biggest things that make
coloring coatings hard are that we don't
have good models for mapping
color differences to data differences
and even with the models that we do have
using color well currently requires
substantial design expertise
so in collaboration with my students as
well as folks at tableau iupui and lanl
what i've looked to do is figure out how
can we better model and understand what
it means to use color well in order to
drive algorithmic solutions that help
people use color more effectively
so a lot of my work in the space fits
into two primary threads
how do people see colors and biz and how
do we design algorithms that help people
use color more effectively
a lot of this has been very
methodological focusing on how we can
model the ways people perceive colors
directly as a function of the design
components of the visualization so what
these techniques aim to do is let us use
experimental data to probabilistically
model how precisely people can discern
color differences across a wide range of
visualization designs and once we
figured out how people see differences
in color we can look more globally
developing metrics and algorithms for
choosing sets of color that effectively
communicate properties of our data
for today i'll focus more on the
algorithmic side of this work
specifically exploring how we can use
data mining practices to automatically
bootstrap color encoding design
so to set the stage for a lot of this
work the viz community has historically
used the cie lab color space rather than
rgb as a way to map color to data
lab consists of three axes that
essentially mimic the cells in the eye
and we can use lab for viz is unlike rgb
it's what we call approximately
perceptually linear that is one unit of
euclidean distance
approximately corresponds to one fifty
percent just noticeable for j and d
which is the smallest difference that
people can reliably distinguish and rate
greater than chance
so ca the cia lab gives us this really
nice one-to-one mapping between data and
color differences that's critical for
data analysis and that in practice fails
absolutely miserably so let me show you
how
cie lab states that we should be able to
see seven different colors in this bar
chart
no need to adjust your monitor as you
can probably see this expectation just
simply doesn't pan out
so this designers have hand tuned color
sets for data representation using
decades of experience to employ these
models as heuristics in crafting better
encodings
by essentially just using well-defined
and well-developed intuitions however
even these encodings can start to break
down as we change the size of our marks
or even as we change the kinds of
visualizations that we're using
and encodings we want to figure out how
do we balance discriminability the
ability to preserve important data
differences with the range of desired
data differences we need to encode based
on the data sets that we have
so to achieve this goal we created a
different method to proactively
anticipate how color difference
perceptions change as a function of the
visualizations that we use
that is we wanted to create models that
allow us to match the differences we see
in colors to the differences that exist
in our data we developed three different
models using this approach the first
focusing on what we call diagonally
symmetric marks like points in a scanner
plot the second on elongated marks like
bars and a bar chart and the third on
asymmetric elongated marks like lines in
a line graph in total we collected over
34 000 data points to see these models
across a range of crop reviewers
for the sake of time i'm going to skip
the nitty gritty of these methods i'm
more than happy to chat about the
details of these experiments online or
you can check them out in the paper
but i do want to touch on what it is
that we found
so our studies show that our ability to
perceive differences in data encoded by
color vary according to the design of
our visualization and in particular
to elongation are asymptotic but could
be quite dramatic so this dependent
models predict that we lose about 70 of
the data differences predicted by cie
lab in practice
but when we consider the geometries of a
data point we can actually buy back
about 30 percent of that difference
meaning we can resolve differences a lot
more reliably if we choose colors that
are tailored to our visualization design
and the other cool bit with these
results is just how cleanly we can make
these predictions we actually were able
to compute normalizing constants using a
range of allowable mark sizes the feeden
or euclidean distance formulation in
order to predict with a surprisingly
high degree of precision how well people
could actually discern color-coded data
in bits
so one of the ways we might use these
models is to evaluate our own practices
and understand where current approaches
may fall
so you'll recall that designers often
will hand adjust for the short ci lab
and most color invis comes from a tool
called color brewer
ramps and color are hand designed
typically considered the gold standard
set of encodings available for people to
use so we can use our computational
models to predict the effectiveness of
existing encodings based on known
minimum parameters of the viz for
example imagine that we have scatter
plots with 10 pixel wide points and line
graphs with four pixel thick lines these
roughly correspond to the standards that
we see
on a 15 inch laptop
so we can use our models to anticipate
which of our nine step brewer sequential
encodings that designer that we're
designed for using cartography
will be robust to these scatter plots
and line graphs that is which will allow
us to distinguish between each of our
nine steps and which are likely to
create ambiguities in our data
using our models we actually found that
13 of the 18 color brewery encodings
actually failed to preserve sufficient
color differences for these
visualizations
and so this failure of these ramps
suggests the need to consider markerware
models in encoding design we're actually
losing much of the fidelity that we
assume even in expert crafted designs
due to assumptions about fixed
discriminability embedded in
conventional models
so this kind of creates a big problem it
suggests that we need to rethink the
ways that we craft ramps
so as we saw earlier designers have a
fine-tuned sense of how to build good
coloring coatings but
even they don't have it perfectly
correct yes
however it's really hard for the vast
majority of us to generate colors with
high perceptual and aesthetic quality
it's just hard to do well and it's also
incredibly time consuming so what's the
average visualization developer to do or
to put this more simply how do we choose
the right colors for our data especially
as data grows in both size and
complexity
well one approach we can use is to apply
our models to proactively fix encoding
challenges to encourage effective
visualizations support experimentation
and even conduct postdoc correction
so for example if we design a scatter
plot like we see here we like our color
choices
we may actually lose important
differences in the data as our points
shrink due to factors like added data or
smaller displays
we can use our models to anticipate when
this will happen push apart the ends of
our encoding
and then re-interpolate the encoding to
preserve uniformity
similarly if our visualizations change
we can use our metrics to pull colors
closer together to make better use of
the available encoding space and allow
more room for aesthetic choice
so this approach is great if you have a
solid baseline selecting from a set of
predefined tools
might also lead to a little bit of deja
vu
as you can see in this set of visits
from the 2018 proceedings of the visual
analytics track at the top biz
conference we use color a lot and maybe
rely a bit more heavily than we realize
on can ramps like those created by color
brewer
in fact in just a brief survey of that
track we found 25 percent of papers from
that proceeding contained at least one
viz with a red blue ramp
so essentially this is causing your
visualization to blend in with the crowd
even if you're okay with your viz not
standing out there are situations where
we may need unique colors for example if
we're working on branded presentations
we may need to use the colors associated
with that brand
but there's not exactly a ton of demand
out there for a lift pink ramp well so
what are we to do well this leads us to
the challenge we've tackled in this work
which is how do we enable people to
create effective custom qual ramps
to solve this we developed a simple
algorithm that lets you create high
quality um ramps using just a single
guiding color so in this case let's use
skype blue
well we can accomplish this by computing
characteristic structures in designer
ramps
interpolated in a perceptual color space
we can then apply those ramps to a given
color to generate a set of color ups
with different visual characteristics
that developers can select from and
refine
so most color ramp design methods lie
along a spectrum from tools that offer
pre-designed palettes like color brewer
to those that allow full control of the
user like photoshop so selecting from a
set of chan ramps is great
if one of the handful of ramps that you
can choose from meets your needs exactly
but you have no means for adjusting them
what you see really is what you get
on the other hand tools like color
picker for data seen here on the right
provide a lot more agency to the user
you can choose two endpoints in a
perceptual space and interpolate those
endpoints at equal intervals
but you have no guidance for choosing
those colors
and this all gets to the interesting and
nuanced recommendations we have for
building effective color ramps so what i
have listed out here is a set of 17 best
practices from a recent survey exploring
decades of color use and fizz however
coloring design is really hard it
combines aspects of perception and
aesthetics in ways that have to play
nice with each other and many of these
concepts are heuristics that require
substantial design expertise to apply
effectively
so i'm going to remove all the
guidelines that fall into this heuristic
category and leave only the concrete
mathematical guidelines
now that i have these i'm going to
remove those that are really hard to
implement to design time without
substantial color science expertise
and here's our results
so hopefully you're seeing now why
creating ramps is pretty hard
and even if you have the expertise to
follow many of these practices we've
actually found that in practice
designers don't typically follow many of
these rules
so what are we going to do well
we turned instead to a concept called
design mining which is an approach that
uses data mining to model and reproduce
design practices and we use this design
mining approach to capture the
properties of effective color use in
visualization
our algorithm relies on the fundamental
observation that ramps are essentially
just curves constructed and interpolated
in a 3d space
so we assert that the structure of the
curve controls the aesthetic appearance
of a ramp and the way is that we sample
the curve control the perceptual
properties of the ramp
these curves could traverse the 3dci lab
volume but that gets a little
mind-bending when you're trying to look
at these volumes on a 2d display so i'm
going to just show these as a series of
projected 2d curves
one in hue space on the left and one in
lightness and chroma on the right
so our algorithm consists of six steps
roughly categorized into three phases
the first two steps create a uniform
training corpus we use to derive our
models
the second to cluster the curves based
on their structural properties and
compute characteristic structures
describing each cluster
and the final pair takes these clusters
from an abstract space and anchors them
in color space to generate our encodings
i'll walk through each of these at a
high level here but as always happy to
dive into more detail after the talk
so we started with a corpus of 222
handcrafted color ramps from known
sources in the community including color
lovers tableau r and color brewer and we
use this corpus as the training set for
our model
we normalized each of these ramps by
treating the colors in the ramp as
control points and fitting interpolating
b splines to these points once we had
our splines constructed we used arc
length interpolation to resample the
curves to uniform number of points along
roughly equidistant intervals in cie lab
we clustered the normalized curves
according to their physical structures
again more details about this
mathematically are in the paper but i
want to show you a little bit of the
results so here the 2d projected plots
of these curves are shown in gray and
the basic idea is that we can align
these curves by moving rotating and
reflecting them to minimize the overall
distance between control points
we then use either acadian's clustering
based on structural features of each
curve or a bayesian clustering algorithm
applied to an elastic shape descriptor
to group curves sharing similar
structures
once we've done this grouping we can
compute a characteristic curve for each
cluster
by identifying the mean structure from
our set of curves
and as you can see here in these
projected plots most of these curves are
far from the linear and uniform
structures that are recommended by
design heuristics or design tools like
color picker for data where we're doing
just this linear interpolation in a
perceptual color space
instead they kind of wiggle all over the
place in interesting ways that create
subtle but would turn out to be critical
affective shifts
so once we have our characteristic curve
we can apply that curve to generate a
ramp by adjusting the curve according to
the relative lightness distribution
basically we start with the curve
positioned according to the mean
lightness model and we then find a point
in the curve that is closest to our
desired color
once we found this point we shift the
ramp such that we minimize the lightness
variation from our original model
and then anchor the resulting ramp in
color space to get our new color ramp
we tested this approach in three ways
including a direct replication of
existing designer practices
and stress testing with poor color
choices
and we also conducted a formal study
with professional designers to evaluate
the perceptual and aesthetic
characteristics of our ramp
so details about the first two
evaluation methods are in the paper and
for the sake of time i'm just going to
touch briefly on our experimental
evaluation
so in this evaluation we pseudo randomly
seeded 25 ramps using models generated
from the two different clustering
algorithms and compared these with two
baseline approaches
so our generated curves are shown here
on the right and we compared these with
first a linear baseline
where we linearly interpolated between
two colors at least 40 units of
lightness apart selected from our
designer corpus
and then we used a designer baseline
where we chose 25 ramps directly from
our designer corpus at random so this
baseline gives us a theoretical
threshold for what a high quality
coloring coding should look like
and we use these ramps in a series of
visualizations where participants
completed a target identification task
finding the point in the ramp closest to
a given value to test the perceptual
discriminability of each ramp
we use stimuli with an aesthetic
question simply asking people to select
how pleasant they found the colors in
the viz to be
so we conducted the study with three
different visualization types scatter
plots heat maps and chloroplast maps we
recruited 35 designers from around the
world to complete the study and our
designers had an average of 6.2 years of
self-reported professional design
experience
cutting to the chase here we can
actually categorize these results
according to both our perceptual so kind
of the how good is this ramp for a
typical visualization task and aesthetic
measures so in these graphs you'll see
our approach in green and the baselines
in blue so for our perceptual measures
we found that participants were actually
more accurate with our approach than
with linear ramps and tended towards
being more accurate with our approach
than with designers designer ramps so i
should note that that was a trending
towards it was not statistically
significant
we found the same pattern with
aesthetics participants tended to prefer
our approach to linearly interpolated
ranch
and found our models at least as
aesthetically pleasing as designer ramps
so the main takeaway here is that for
these visualizations we find that expert
participant pool found ramps generated
using our approach comparable to those
handcrafted by designers
well to make these results a little more
actionable we embedded our models in a
coloring coding design tool called color
crafter that essentially provides a
front end for this algorithm the tool
allows people to specify target colors
to generate a set of ramps they can
manipulate those ramps using a sequence
of affine transformations including
translation rotation scaling and
reflection along all the various axes of
color space
the transformation edits allow users to
quickly customize their encodings
without sacrificing the quality of the
resulting rail
and through this approach even novice
visualization designers and developers
can rapidly create custom color ramps
that embody best practices in
visualization design and it only really
requires them to specify one single
guiding color
so you can see an example of some of the
results of this approach here for fun i
seated a set of ramps using carolina
blue and you can see the results by
inputting the target color into the tool
we're actually able to generate a series
of color encodings to choose from then
i'll adhere to our designer properties
all include our target color but have
slightly different affects and slightly
different aesthetic quality
so
as promised i wouldn't briefly revisit
how this work embodies my research
approach
we started by characterizing the problem
of why it's hard to choose good colors
for this showing that it's a complex
multi-dimensional space and
considerations
from there we develop probabilistic
models of how people perceive colors in
viz
um and we use these models to see an
algorithm and corresponding tool to
bootstrap encoding design so the end
result of this process is fundamental
knowledge of how visitors work
models that allow us to make them better
and tools that make it easier for people
to create good visualizations
and as i mentioned i want to toss out a
little discussion of some of our ongoing
work in case folks are interested in
following up about potential
collaboration and one challenge that's
come up in discussions with geologists
and other in the earth sciences is how
drastically different color maps can
change the kinds of structures they see
in their data so we're currently
exploring how we can interactively infer
the parameters of ideal encoding choice
by mining user preferences between color
map designs
applied to a scientist's own data using
bayesian optimization we're also
exploring alternative methods for using
statistical models of viz viewed in
automated settings
so under um some of the work that's been
recently funded as part of my career
we're starting to investigate how we can
use statistical models of viz
statistical models of vis-interpretation
across a range of designs to try to
automate the process of estimating how
well a given viz will communicate a
specific set of patterns and the aim
here is providing intelligent design
support tools through rapid situated
evaluation
so next i want to pivot away from color
and touch on a different aspect of my
research which is how do we leverage
cognitive processing in visualization
design so we have a wide range of
projects in this area ranging from
looking at behavior and decision making
to the point i want to talk about today
which is actually understanding
cognitive accessibility so data is being
used to justify a wide range of policies
and decisions but who are we leaving out
in our current data communication
practices
this project aims to understand barriers
in existing practice for people with
intellectual and developmental
disabilities and to develop principles
for overcoming these barriers so a lot
of the work i'm going to talk about is
still ongoing but i wanted to spend more
time talking about the work in this
space that has been published
so this work is motivated in large part
by a collaboration with the coleman
institute for intellectual and
developmental disabilities they're very
interested in self-advocacy that is how
can people with disabilities have more
agency in the policies that affect them
policy making is increasing by data
we've seen that especially in light of
all of the recent data that's come out
in the epidemiological space
but in conversations with psychiatrists
clinicians and care partners current
tools for analytics simply are not
working for people with intellectual
developmental disability and we wanted
to understand why and how we could do
better
part of understanding why is challenging
the fundamental assumption and
visualization that everyone processes
visual information in the same way
people with idd have differences that
emerge in the visual information
processing components of the human
cognitive system so we turn to education
and psychology to try to understand
where our current assumptions might be
falling short
and in ongoing work we're taking more of
a generative approach
trying to understand um
how what kinds of representations are
intuitive for people with idd using more
of a participatory design approach since
this work is ongoing i want to focus on
the first thread that is what best
practices are or aren't working for
people with idd
and i want to take a step back to
explain what i mean by idd so ipd or
intellectual and developmental
disability is characterized by
limitations in social conceptual or
practical skills and it affects over 200
million people worldwide these
disabilities often result in differences
in memory attention visual comprehension
or math comprehension and as you might
imagine
all of these are critical skills for
people trying to work with data
visualizations
in practice these limitations mean that
the sheer complexity of existing tools
including complex multi-view designs
challenges and interaction and building
insights over time that traditional
tools like tableau and power bi are
designed to support
end up being prohibitively challenging
in interviews with psychiatrists and
through our own observations from the
educational literature we actually
devised a few specific interventions
that might challenge existing biz
guidelines
but have the potential to enhance
accessibility
the first of these is probing
just what charts will work
uh so in this we tend to have this
concept of chart choosers i recommend
they are recommenders systems that
choose the single best biz for a given
task or given type of statistic we want
to interrogate
however we know from interviews that pie
charts for example are totally
inaccessible and we wanted to explore as
how well different charts might support
given tasks and if this differs from our
conventional practices in our
conventional chart users and
visualization
we also wanted to explore the idea of
discretization so this suggests that
continuous representations like lines
and bars are simple clean and optimal
our research in mathematical processing
for children with intellectual
disabilities runs contrary to this while
kid's abilities to generalize abstract
quantities is limited studies show that
the approximate number system which is
essentially the ability to roughly
interpret how many objects are present
in a scene
or people with idd may be comparably
efficient to traditional populations
meaning that discretization may actually
be quite beneficial
and in visualization using semantic
information like we see here is actually
kind of a big no-no it adds visual
complexity with questionable benefit
however research and education shows
semantic pictograms actually
significantly enhance visual visual
reasoning for children with down
syndrome and we wanted to explore if
different methods for visual semantics
might have a similar effect in data
representation so to try to probe a lot
of these questions we designed a mixed
method study exploring the effects of
chart type discretization and visual
semantics with 34 participants with and
without idd looking at proportion and
time series data in a series of fiscal
self-advocacy questions
we collected data about objective
performance across different tasks as
well as subjective data about preference
and usability i'll leave details about
the methods the q a or the paper but the
tldr is that we found traditional biz
guidelines
make data inaccessible
so we were able to generate four key
design guidelines for enhancing data
accessibility
the first of these is resonates pretty
well with what we had heard from
practitioners that we just want to avoid
pie charts people with idd perform
significantly worse than chance using
pies whereas performance with stack bar
charts or tree maps was comparable to
our non-idd participants
and while we found mixed effects on the
use of semantics using familiar
metaphors sparingly such as just this
very clean iconography actually greatly
increased data comprehension we found in
our subjective feedback that these
effects were directly related to this
idea of comprehension people saw the
semantics the meaning of the data when
they looked at the charts and it made it
easier to try to make sense of the
information they were processing
people with idd also relied more heavily
on visual metaphors like bars when
making staircases or trees tree maps
from making pieces of paper as part of
their visual reasoning processes
we also found that semantics could be
prohibitive overly complex
representations performed poorly and
both objectively and subjectively
the true takeaways people just felt
overwhelmed and it took significantly
more time to try to complete the task
when representations were more complex
finally discretization also helped some
we found that when discrete marks were
axis aligned like we see here in this
bar chart performance and preference
were both high however when they were
not access aligned as in the pie chart
here on the right people found
themselves resorting to counting
strategies
leading to longer time on task and lower
overall preference
so we're actively working on this
problem as there's still so much to
understand and do to make this work
actionable and one of the projects that
we're gearing up to run is a
participatory design workshop that will
explore how people with idd naturally
tackle simple data communication
problems related to everyday life
we're also working with the coleman
institute to explore how we might
automatically adapt visualizations to
become more accessible and my student
kikibu has been working with them to
change their products like their chart
builder to use more accessible practices
so for the final thread that i want to
walk you through today i'm actually
going to talk a little bit about how we
can move data off the monitor and into
the real world using augmented reality
to allow people to explore data within
the context that data describes
leading hopefully it's a more timely and
actionable analysis
and the driving problem behind this work
is data use in field research and
emergency response so in these scenarios
data is typically collected in the field
with scientists and responders carefully
assessing field sites in small teams
at the end of the day or even at the end
of the operation this data is brought
back to the command center for analysis
using traditional analytics tools
so in interviews with a range of experts
in these fields we found that it was
almost universal practice
but that this process introduced some
problematic divides for example it
removed analysis from the times and
places where people could actually do
something with the data for example one
scientist described flying a large
fixed-wing drone in a remote sign in
greenland
um running a month-long survey and
returning home only to realize that a
good chunk of their data simply didn't
record so this ends up being a million
dollar mistake
we talked to analysts they noticed that
analyzing data out of context meant that
people in the field were actually
operating on stale data and in the
emergency response scenarios this could
create potentially life-threatening
applica situations
especially when we're talking about
things like search and rescue or
wildland fire where field sites might be
dynamically changing
we also found that this paradigm meant
that most analysts didn't have any
access to the context that the data
described and if they found errors or
key information in their data they
simply weren't a position to act on
those observations
because they weren't out in the field
they were back in the operations center
so in this line of work
we're looking to understand how we might
design immersive analytics tools that
leverage non-traditional displays to
embed the analysts within the data to
overcome these temporal and spatial gaps
in analysis
in other words how can we shift from
seeing data as a thing that lives in a
spreadsheet
to one part of a larger often dynamic
space where data is informed by situated
context and can immediately inform
action and decision
so my work in the space predominantly
approaches this challenge from two sides
bottom up through design and perception
experiments and top down through
application
on the design side we're thinking about
how do we create visualizations
seamlessly blend the real and virtual
worlds and we're specifically using an
empirical approach to understand how the
ways we visualize data in augmented
reality
shift our perceptions of that data both
in terms of its relation to the real
world and its ability to effectively
convey critical statistics
on the application side we're taking
more of a problem-driven approach to
understand how visualizations can
leverage the capabilities of immersive
devices for people to use data more
effectively
for example in collaboration with nrel
we explored how experiential data
storytelling in augmented reality
could help communicate the use and
benefits of hydrogen fueling more
effectively than traditional 2d media
like a slideshow
so part of the challenge of designing
such systems and why we lack guidelines
for effectively visualizing data in ar
is that visualization has a long
love-hate relationship with 3d we know
that on 2d monitors 3d visualizations
can cause a lot of problems for example
3d pie charts like this distort
perceived percentages it can be really
tricky to try to resolve the individual
dots in 3d scatter plots or heights and
3d bar charts and we even see these
tools as adding labels to try and
simplify this task
well not using 3d is conventional design
wisdom for traditional bids
but it's also possible that stereoscopic
viewing in ar and vr may actually reopen
this channel for visualization and i see
we've got a hand up if you want to go
ahead and jump in
um
yeah i wasn't sure when to interrupt or
not but i guess i figured
so i see uh some of them uh had a lot of
different hypothesis tests and kind of
these very interesting ways of trying to
think about the the
yeah the process so it seems almost
database seems to be like a bundle of
decisions a lot of the time that seems
to kind of almost like meld together and
i was wondering if you could uh
comment a little bit about how
do you see of what exactly is being
falsified when you do some kind of
hypothesis test uh particularly on the
last section and and here i think even
more so so when you're trying to compare
these these different slides in and how
you exactly attribute these comparisons
back to a given hypothesis so for
example you think you had some donuts
and then
then that was the line but then it seems
like you know oh but this one has an
axis the other one doesn't have an axis
and the different ways and like what
exactly are you yeah thank you
yeah so i mean i don't like we try to
sample a long a continuum and right we
can think of this
continuum as being from reductionist
evaluation to holistic evaluation so the
more holistic side we're trying to get
to that point of ecological validity
where the kinds of things we're
assessing reflect what people are doing
in practice and the environments they're
viewing things in in practice so for
example in the last study with
intellectual and developmental
disability we're really thinking about
this idea of how do people interpret
this kind of fiscal data in common
representations so we use statistical
tasks to collect the objective data but
we also use subjective measures to have
people walk us through what are they
seeing why do they prefer it what makes
sense what doesn't what's easy what's
hard um so that's how we're trying to
get it the more holistic evaluation and
there are even examples which i don't
have time to talk about today where the
way we evaluate something is we build
something put it out in the wild and see
what knowledge people get and what
findings they generate so that's that
kind of far side of holistic evaluation
there's also the very reductionist side
which is where we want to try to
understand specific aspects of this to
try to make very low level design
guidance and so a lot of what i'm going
to get to here in a minute with this
study is focusing on that for example we
want to understand what are the
affordances of immersive analytics what
happens when i take data off the screen
and put it in a headset put it in ar put
it in vr and how my designs need to
change and a lot of these kinds of
studies often occur very early in the
design process because they're the kinds
of things that just are providing our
fundamental mappings and are ensuring
that the way data is represented
actually reflects the differences that
truly exist in our data so we're looking
at in that case measuring very
controlled differences in our
representation and trying to model how
the small variations in those
differences
translate to differences in
interpretation so i think to do
effective visualization to generate
effective guidelines we really need
samples all along that continuum from
the low level concrete quantitative
decisions the high level more subjective
more qualitative notions of how do these
low-level pieces all come together and
interact in interesting ways to try to
help us understand what makes that
visualization tick
cool awesome and that's actually a great
segue into
this next experiment unless you have a
quick follow on there
yeah very
oh i think you might be muted
so should you very quickly so my
understanding then is you would merge
both data sets at some point and
try to think about a kind of a quality
based approach as well as
concrete guidance on those different
qualities in some sense so i change
colors from red to blue
and i people said that red the change
from red to blue is not very good yeah
and the basic idea is that by having all
this data we're actually empowering
designers to do that merging and to make
the trade-offs in their specific
scenarios and in the specific context of
working in um i'm not convinced that we
can do that at this point automatically
i don't think we can totally replace the
human intuition and design but that's a
whole philosophical argument for later
cool
cool so the the a great point following
up on this though is that
not using 3d is conventional design
wisdom for traditional viz and some of
the leading figures in the field of
immersive analytics tend to think that
we generally want to follow the same
kinds of rules that we see in
traditional viz and in ar and br that
these kinds of 3d stereoscopic immersive
displays
may not actually fundamentally change
for example the fact that 3d isn't
always very good
um so some of these guidelines that you
see here may feel a little bit
counter-intuitive given the importance
of immersive devices such as the idea
that 3d perspective doesn't help or that
3d nav is hard to do and where
when we do it every day in the real
world and we wanted to test how these
ideas hold up in practice again getting
that idea of the kind of low-level
design specification
so we investigated what happened so we
asked people to use the same
visualization on a desktop versus in vr
versus an ar
and so in the study people use 2d and 3d
visualizations encoding data using a
range of visual channels such as color
and size to estimate a series of
different statistics and we compared how
quickly and accurately people completed
these tasks as well as how much they
interacted with the data
and while i can chat about specific
results online the takeaway here is that
the same visualizations perform
differently on the desktop ar and vr
conditions in other words this design is
not one-size-fits-all displays but
rather we need different guidance
depending on the kinds of displays we're
using
so to highlight a few of our findings on
a 2d monitor it's really hard to resolve
whether a 3d scatter point or bar is
either smaller or further away from a
larger point however showing the same
scatter plot in ar or vr allowed people
to more readily disentangle size and
depth potentially reopening this
dimension
we saw an opposing effect for color
people struggle to interpret color-coded
data in ar and we can see an example of
this here putting the points over darker
objects makes points appear lighter and
vice versa so we kind of get this muting
effect of our color choices this is
related to a phenomenon known as
simultaneous contrast
and while ar degraded color
interpretation we actually found that it
increased engagement people walked
around and interacted with data
significantly more in ar than either the
desktop or vr and subjectively noted
that they were actually more comfortable
interacting with data in ar
still a ton more new impact here but
this offers interesting questions for
interaction design and immersive
analytics
and the larger takeaway from the study
is that we need new guidelines and
practices for designing effective data
visualizations using emerging
technologies
we explored some of these possible
designs in fieldvue which is a prototype
toolkit for field-based analytics so
building on a series of interviews with
scientists and emergency responders we
developed a multi-device application to
support field data collection analysis
practices
so our solution couples a mobile
application for data collection overview
analysis with detailed contextualized
visualizations in ar and the workflow
for this tool starts with our data
collection app where field analysts can
input a variety of information it's
automatically geotagged the information
is cached and when connected synced with
cloud data store or local network where
members of a field team can access a
common data store
and analysts then pull down this data
and view summary overview visualizations
on mobile devices or project geotagged
data into the real world to explore this
data in a situated context
so we released fieldvue as an open
source toolkit including a prototype
mobile overview and immersive detail
visualizations for three common
scenarios noted in our discussions with
analysts coordinating data collection
activities over a local team monitoring
data quality during field collection and
accessing data collected by autonomous
sensors such as overhead drones
to give you just a very quick overview
of how these visualizations work here
you see a scatter plot or a stratified
grid on a field site a team member can
identify regions of uncollected data
which are shown here in these big blue
squares and these areas are replaced by
situated color-coded scatter plot values
when data is provided analysts can then
go ahead and move into the missing areas
to collect new data and you'll see the
overlay disappears when the analysis is
within the missing region to avoid
including field of view
so this next example shows how we might
use the fieldview interface to connect
with aerial imagery that's collected by
a drone the scatter plot points indicate
available imagery with colors
corresponding to temperature measures
collected by drone sensor we can click
on the points to show the overhead data
with the images remaining just outside
the central field of view to preserve
the analyst's abilities to maintain
awareness of the environments
the points in the periphery indicate
data outside the user's primary view
with their size and position cueing to
distance and orientation relative to the
user so the basic idea here is that
we're trying to use this overhead
imagery to provide immediate context for
current operations and to monitor
autonomous data collection operations in
real time while still maintaining
overall awareness and the responders
ability to operate within their local
environment
everything here is still quite
preliminary but artwork in the space
eliminated number of interesting
questions at the intersection of
robotics and data analytics for
emergency response operations that
myself and my collaborators are
currently exploring
i'm also in the preliminary phase of
exploring how we can design
visualizations that intelligently adapt
to user surroundings to maximize
information gain while minimizing
interference with the environment
for example we're looking at how we can
use information about lighting and
seeing composition to make better color
choices or how we might adapt the
complexity of a viz based on movement in
the local environments so part of
addressing these questions is also
understanding how the context provided
by situated this can actually a data
comprehension and decision making and in
turn how designs might best take
advantage of such games
so in the interest of time i'm just
going to sum up really quickly here
we've looked at three threads of
research to demonstrate the processes i
used to create effective visualization
systems for data exploration
starting with this idea of how do we use
color more effectively and moving into
how this might mediate human machine
teaming with large data sets in a mixed
initiative anal or sorry in uh
in uh cognitive accessibility and
finally exploring how ar can reduce
potential spatial and temporal gaps
analysis for applications like
environmental science and emergency
response and this represents a lot of
the work that we've done to date we have
lots of other fun work that's going on
between looking at using um hardware and
wearables to promote data science
literacy looking at collaborative human
machine teaming looking at the interface
of robotics and fizz and also looking at
how we might use making and papercraft
to build
informal activities for early childhood
data literacy
if folks are interested in connecting
about any of these projects please do
reach out for the sake of time i think
i'm just going to cut here to the end
and thank my collaborators
thank you all for having me today thank
you for you know listening and also take
any questions that you all might have
i'm looking forward to the discussion
hi
thanks so much for for a great talk
um i had a follow-up question regarding
kind of ar and color so you talked about
your work uh studying color and
um the importance of selecting selecting
that color and also your work in and
understanding
the challenges that ar poses in
selecting color given the background and
you briefly mentioned kind of looking at
lighting and seeing composition to to
select colors appropriately and i was
wondering if you can talk a little bit
more about
what makes color important in ar and
is there
reasons for maybe exploring other visual
attributes like motion or things that
may uh kind of not have the same issues
in ar uh and if not what uh
how can we kind of look at um
uh using perception
to kind of correct some of those issues
with color and different backgrounds
yeah series of great questions there's a
ton to impact there um i would say you
know one of the things i didn't have
time to talk about in that study is we
actually generated a ranking of what
visualization techniques or what visual
channels work best for which modalities
and this is where you know color was not
as good in ar as other modalities so if
we think about trying to privilege other
like position or size that might be more
precise
this understanding where color sits with
respect to all this allows us to
understand when do we actually need to
take on that challenge of working with
color
how we do it is going to be a little
more complicated color tends to be
really really good for
high level kinds of statistics when i
need to do things like estimating
averages or also for drawing attention
very very quickly right if i see a red
point in the field of blue points i'm
going to look right at it and so i think
those are the situations where we need
to think about
are there ways of making color better or
in ar do there happen to be better ways
of achieving the same kind of tasks and
i think there's a lot of open-ended
questions that
i'm looking forward to seeing where
things go because i think there's lots
and lots of cool stuff that could come
out of that
thank you so much great talk
i have a question thanks so much for
this really exciting talk and i think
kind of following up on the question um
you know you talked a little bit about
uh in in terms of ar vr
and then kind of a desktop side of
things it seems like there's a lot to
unpack there in terms of both like
different techniques for interactive
perception and the different ways in
which a person can interact with it but
then also on the low level perceptual
side and you know there it seems like a
big difference is in terms of these
depth cues
and you know there are lots of different
you know cues that we use for depth and
i'm wondering you know how much of this
is connected to the specific display
technology that we have versus inherent
in you know ar vr etc
yeah i mean it's a great question in
that study we were trying to minimize
the variation so we actually were using
either pass through with the um htc vive
and the zen mini or we were using just
the htc
vive so
we were trying to really minimize the
amount of device variation but that's
really going to be a thing especially
when you start to think about things
like interaction plus perception plus
field of view if i'm only seeing a small
portion of the display and i'm losing
all the information that's coming in the
periphery how is that changing my
decision making how is it changing how i
choose to move and interact in the space
so i think there are a lot of parameters
of the display technologies and display
hardware and the ways that changes how
we might intuitively interact with the
the representations that are still to be
explored and are really critical when we
think about how do we put these these
ideas into actionable contexts and
there's even the broader point that we
ran into that i
glossed over because it's a really hard
hardware challenge which is what happens
when we take these technologies outside
you'll notice all of our videos we're on
very cloudy days
it's because on bright and sunny days
you can't see anything in the headsets
so this is another challenge that
pertains to displays and perception and
all of the rich environmental contexts
that come into play
once you actually start to put these
things out into practice so i think that
this is a long way of saying we still
need a lot more work because all of
these different factors are definitely
come together going to come together and
influence efficacy and influence design
yeah
can i ask a question go for it yep sorry
yeah yeah uh yeah thank you for your
talk um so you mentioned uh the study
like comparing the arvr and the
2d like 2d analytics but do you have any
suggestions on like when to do the like
immersive and want to do 2d because some
people might argue like what is
necessary to do ar vr especially given
like 2d might be more accessible like
the smartphones laptops are more
like more often used than the ar vr has
said
so um it's interesting you bring this up
so we discussed this there is a paper
that came out at kai last year in grand
challenges for immersive analytics where
this was a huge point for us is figuring
out
what situations does it make sense to
use immersive spaces versus when does it
make sense to use traditional you know
desktop-based analytics
and my argument would be that there are
two situations that really come to mind
um this is just just my own opinion from
my own experiences this is not something
that's yet backed by data but there are
two situations in particular where this
kind of immersive space can make a lot
of sense
um one of these is when you're situating
data when having the context of the
physical environment is actually going
to
affect the kinds of decisions that you
need to make so if i am looking at a
burning structure and then i see my
scanner plot about the current heat map
distributor or heat temperature
distributions in the local region
that's going to give me a whole lot more
information it's going to be a whole lot
more actionable
um the same it comes into play when
you're starting to think about these
kinds of um
basically putting
information in the space where we need
to be able to act right i can
bring around my phone with me but
anytime i'm doing analytics on a phone
right this is why we don't do texting
and driving you have divided attention i
can pay full attention to my phone i can
pay full attention to what i'm doing and
i'm moving my attention back and forth
between devices so i would say the
second scenario is in those cases where
divided attention is less than ideal um
so those are more cases where having
that situated nature might be really
helpful and a lot of this might come
down to things like ambient situational
awareness that's promoted by
always having that display available to
you
but maybe you're not always fully
attending to the display and if you need
full attention you can bring that data
back out into the environment so those
would be the two cases that i would
posit that this kind of situatedness is
actually beneficial beyond what we have
on a 2d display there are interesting
questions about interactive affordances
about the role of immersion about how
immersion and you know physical
reconstruction in space might actually
influence spatial comprehension but i
don't think we have enough in the
immersive analytics space
yet to say whether those benefits
outweigh the trade-offs of moving into
this new modality
yeah thank you
that's a good question this is all
getting into stuff that i think music
fields still need to figure out
this is great all right well if there
aren't any other questions then let's
thank danielle for that really exciting
talk and yeah thanks so much
you